Game of Thrones fans can attest to a big truth:
if you don't pay close enough attention to
what's happening on screen, you'll miss out
on a ton of ton of tiny details.
This certainly applied to the first episode
of Thrones' eighth and final season.
The premiere featured plenty of buzz-worthy
moments — like the heartwarming reunion
between Jon and Arya, the awkward reunion
between Jon and Bran, the dramatic reunion
between Bran and Jaime Lannister, plus that
dragon joyride and Jon discovering he's a
Targaryen and Daenerys not giving a single
hoot about telling Sam she burnt his family
alive.
"Least I'll be allowed home again, now that
my brother's the lord"
What has people talking even more than all
that are the two blink-and-you'll-miss-them
cameos that most people didn't pick up on
the first time around — you know, on account
of everything else happening during the episode.
In the season 8 premiere, there's a scene
in which Theon Greyjoy storms his uncle Euron's
ship, making his way to his sister Yara, Before
he can rescue her, however, Theon has to pick
off a few members of Euron's fleet.
Theon's hand is steady as he fires an arrow
clean into the back of one man's skull, sending
it shooting out his eye.
He and two men behind him put several more
arrows through the heads of other random guys
on deck.
The siege is successful, the path to Yara
is clear, and Theon is free to return to Winterfell
while Yara looks over the Ironborn as Queen
of the Iron Islands.
On the surface, the scene doesn't seem out
of the ordinary: it's a calculated act of
violence executed to meet an end goal.
Look closer at the people playing Theon's
victims, though, and you'll see that the sequence
is anything but normal, as it features cameo
appearances from It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
actor Rob McElhenney and Silicon Valley star
Martin Starr.
"They gouged my eye out.
They gouged my f------ eye out."
They aren't on screen for very long and the
dim lighting makes it difficult to recognize
their faces, so it's easy to see why so many
never caught McElhenney and Starr on the season
8 premiere of Game of Thrones.
Well they'll be cutting from your face to
his face, then back to your face, and then
we'll get to see his face again."
With each passing season, the series has gotten
better at sneaking in celebrity cameos that
only the most eagle-eyed viewers can immediately
find.
Over the years, Game of Thrones showrunners
David Benioff and D.B. Weiss
have managed to include musicians,
other actors, and even political figures on
the series.
Even Weiss and Benioff themselves made cameo
appearances, their mugs seen in the Hall of
Faces at the House of Black and White.
And very few could forget the time singer-songwriter
Ed Sheeran appeared on Thrones, playing a
singing Lannister bannerman Arya met as she
was traveling to King's Landing.
While many Game of Thrones fans weren't keen
on Sheeran's cameo, most everyone is loving
that McElhenney and Starr got to be a part
of the series, if only for a few seconds each.
In a way, it marks a full-circle moment: McElhenney
is close friends with Benioff and Weiss, who
previously wrote the season 9 It's Always
Sunny episode "Flowers for Charlie" and made
their own small appearances on the season
12 installment "The Gang Goes to a Water Park."
A longtime Thrones fan, McElhenney was thought
to have already cameoed on the show back in
season 6, appearing alongside his Always Sunny
co-star Charlie Day as Unsullied soldiers,
but that ended up just a rumor.
"You're like what's that rascal Charlie up
to now?
What's he up to this time?
I'm not thinking that at all."
Unfortunately, there's one person who definitely
won't appear on the final season of Game of
Thrones: the mastermind behind the whole thing,
George R.R. Martin.
As it turns out, the A Song of Ice and Fire
author had the opportunity to cameo on season
8, but turned it down in favor of working
on finishing The Winds of Winter, the long-awaited
sixth book in his novel series upon which
the show is based.
In the game of Thrones cameos, you either
accept and play a character who probably dies,
or you decline and deliver on your past promises.
McElhenney and Starr may have had more fun,
but Martin chose wisely.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.